Hello!
Whoever you are, and wherever you came from, welcome to your future!
Now, you're probably wondering where exactly you are,
and who exactly we are.
Unfortunately, that's not something we can tell you at this point.
The purpose of this short educational video is to inform you and your fellow inductees what you should expect
from your new life here at the Foundation.
First of all, you will be given a unique identification number, tatooed directly onto your chest.
We wouldn't want you to lose it, would we?
Hahahaha!
This will become your new name.
You, and every one of your colleagues will be referred to henceforward as Class-D.
The "D" stands for "delightful".
Haha!
Now that you are equipped with your new identity, what's next?
Well, this is where the fun begins.
Let's talk fashion!
Say goodbye to your borin' old clothes.
Here, you will be fitted with our super comfortable standard-issue electric orange overalls,
to keep you warm and cozy while performing your assigned responsibilities,
all the while keeping you looking fresh and professional.
Speaking of responsibilities, let's talk about yours!
Your purpose here is to accommodate your supervisor's demands,
(Those are the friendly guys with the guns)
such as: cleaning up nasty messes,
interacting with interesting characters,
(don't go off script! Hahahaha!)
making sure you're in tip top shape,
(the infirmary is always open!)
and fufilling interdepartmental deliveries,
and much, much more!
You couldn't ask for a more exciting living environment!
Just remember these four simple points, and your time here will be a walk in the park!
Number one, a locked door is a happy door.
Number two, questions are bad.
Number three, supervisor satisfaction is key!
And finally, number four. No pain, no gain.
But it doesn't end here!
If you successfully complete one month of rigorous Class-D work...
...wait for it...
you get to go home, no strings attached! You're free!
I'd say feel free to come back and visit anytime, but
we can't tell you where we are!
Hahahahahahaha!
So, what are you waiting for? Get out there and make us proud like your life depends on it!
Thank you for listening, goodbye, and most importantly, good luck!